flea sociale voici que le bras de fer
aux vedettes tropicale prend aujourd'hui
une tournure plus radicale la troisième
semaine de grève se termine et charles
con comme le patron dégaine l'artillerie
lourde pour lui la grève ne vise qu'à
cacher une situation problématique mais
ça avec aziz basse nous avons depuis
deux mois ont intensifié les contrôles
sur les beaucoup de salariés ont été
pris la main dans le sac parce qu'il
avait dû voir le sud et l'est vous
pouvez demander au client vous le dire
et avec des robes d'un truc était
convoqué cette semaine pour les
entretiens pour nous expliquer les
raisons communes mais différenciées des
problèmes sur les caisses voilà le
problème aujourd'hui le vrai fond du
problème
il ya une plaque qui est un gros con tu
reviens là vous suffisamment d'éléments
pour une équipage l'après terre dans les
mains de mon avocat qui ne devrait pas
tarder à déposer leurs sept salariés
seraient concernés
il aurait reproché non pas un vol
ponctuel mais l'instauration d'un
système de fraude qui durait depuis des
années il revendrait plusieurs fois les
mêmes ticket pour empocher la différence
la deuxième fois cette valse dans sa
poche et je suppose que c'est pas une
deuxième fois seulement puisque j'ai eu
à ramasser des tickets dos le numéro est
sorti depuis octobre 2018 les tickets
des croisiéristes
ça veut dire que ce ticket lakiss aticle
à circulent depuis octobre et ramasser
et revendus et ramasser et revendu
depuis octobre 2018
les dirigeants estiment le préjudice à
300000 euros par an écran de fumée
répond-t-on du côté des employés
affiliés à la cstm le syndicat riposte
d'ailleurs par des accusations de son
cru je rappelle qu'il n'est pas navigant
parce que ce soit un avion et akalé
navigant qui sont habilités à monter sur
les navires comme ça là deuxièmement le
choc on connaître des faits de prêt de
main-d'oeuvre irrégulière et bien sûr le
rachète quatre pilotes
il utilisait deçà des travailleurs qui
sera qui exercent d'associer compagnie
matinée sera sport ou le marché des
classes pilotes qui est pas la même
société
des accusations qui ne change rien à
celle portée par charles conconne alors
sur ces dernières bertrand conduisit
s'interroge sur la coïncidence avec la
grève tout notre la position de la csn
niveau la nicotine mais c'est comme en
disant je rappelle que le code du
travail dispose que dès lors qu'un
employeur a connaissance d'un fait il
doit prendre des mesures qui s'imposent
mais on n'attend pas lorsqu'il ya un
préavis de grève lorsqu'il ya la grève
qui s'est déclenché pour venir apporter
devant la place publique et je ferais
remarquer que jusqu'à aujourd'hui n'a
pas déposé plainte
aucune négociation n'est prévue pour le
moment malgré la demande de la cstm
charles conconne affirment en revanche
qu'il portera plainte dès lundi voilà
qui risque en tout cas de compliquer un
peu les débats